our guest this week on newsmakers is
Anthony Ryan who has been assistant
secretary of the Treasury for financial
markets for the past 15 months and in
that capacity he coordinates the work of
the interagency presidents working group
on financial markets which was
established in 1987 after the turmoil in
the markets at that time and mr. Ryan is
one of Treasury secretary Paulson's
chief deputies in the government action
in the financial market this week and
questioning him this week will be to
reporters who have both had front page
articles in their respective papers
about this current credit crunch joining
us is Greg if he is chief economics
correspondent for The Wall Street
Journal and Neil Irwin the economics
reporter for the wall for the Washington
Post we'll start with you yell there's
Connie Tony I we've heard a lot of talk
this last several weeks in last several
months about the credit markets and how
they function and how they work why why
does this matter to ordinary Americans
why should these obscure markets that
some people have even heard of why do
they matter well we have very
diversified credit markets but they do
play a critically important role in
terms of facilitating economic activity
it matters to every American individuals
who borrow money whether it's through
credit cards whether it's through
mortgages to help finance a home
purchase whether it's through student
loans to help finance education
everybody's impacted by the functioning
of our credit markets and not just on
the borrower side we also have to
recognize that Americans save and as
they say that they invest as they invest
many of those investments are made in
our financial institutions and in other
types of securities that are traded in
our credit markets so they have a role
on both sides and it impacts everybody
and hence our interest in making sure
that our credit markets and our capital
markets are functioning as effectively
as possible so after a wild weekend with
the Bear Stearns action taken by the Fed
and a a very tumultuous several months
how is this past week then are things
stabilizing are things functioning the
way that you're happy with well I think
some of the actions have helped
facilitate more stability and more
orderliness in our capital markets I
think we have to recognize
that the current conditions are a
function of a series of excesses that
have been built up over a number of
years they have created challenges as
some of these changes are occurring but
we're working through that I have a
great deal of confidence in our capital
markets we're addressing these
challenges and we're addressing them
both from a public policy perspective
and certainly some of the actions as
recently as this weekend have helped
facilitate additional liquidity into our
capital markets which helps those
capital markets function more
effectively but the responsibility is
not just that of the public policy
makers and regulators there's also an
important role by our market
participants and they can and are
working through these challenges and i'm
confident they'll continue to do so in
the week sad why are there these your
North problems in the markets the
average person sees the Dow go up and
then go down they see you know their
mortgage rates go up can you explain why
we're having these problems you know it
started in something called subprime
mortgages but a lot of people say I
don't have a subprime mortgage why am i
suffering well it's a great question
right what happened is you're absolutely
right some of the challenges that we are
working through today are not explicitly
directly related to subprime mortgages
but I think it's a great illustration of
how interconnected our capital markets
are today and the trigger that started a
lot of the turmoil was a very grand
expansion of delinquencies with some of
the mortgages that were underwritten
back in 2004-2005 and 2006 and this goes
back to the point I made earlier with
respect to some of the excesses that
were going on and there was a general
weakening of underwriting standards and
credit extension in the mortgage market
place during that period of time and as
a result we had an alarming rate of
delinquencies and some of those
mortgages that were originated that
started the challenges but it quickly
spread to other segments of the capital
structure and had implications not just
in our credit markets but within
financial institutions and not just here
the United States but around the world
and it's another illustration of how
interconnected our markets are not just
across asset class
esas but across geography we read that
the Federal Reserve lent 30 billion
dollars to help bear bear stearns be
taken over by JP Morgan on the weekend
explain to us how this loan works and
the question I think a lot of people
have is you know President Bush's said
no bailouts why is it therefore that
bear stearns in its counterparties get a
bailout but the average homeowner
doesn't get a bailout well I think the
key thing to focus on here is certainly
with respect to the shareholders of bear
stearns they've suffered a significant
loss the focus that we have at the
Treasury Department and with our
colleagues in the regulatory community
is the functioning of our capital
markets the stability in the orderliness
of our capital markets that benefits
everybody that embed if it's the entire
system and we need to see that stability
in our financial institutions and in our
financial marketplace so the actions
taken by the Federal Reserve over the
weekend and there were a series of
actions taken we're all done with the
ambition of facilitating orderliness and
stability in our capital markets and
when those attributes exist additional
liquidity comes into the system and
ultimately continues to enhance investor
confidence and the functioning of these
economic activities that are so
important to both users of credit and
providers of capital why was the 30
billion dollars necessary the portfolio
of actions that were taken were all done
to facilitate liquidity in an ordered
list in the markets the specifics of
that the terms and conditions were
between the counter parties involved in
that transaction but the Fed did seek
the approval of the Treasury for that
particular transaction well we working
in close concert it's very important
that we communicate with each other
understand what's going on share
thoughts and share perspectives and we
focused on what's in the best interest
of the markets what's in the best
interest of stability of the financial
system and we remain in close contact
with the Federal Reserve if you look
where bear stearns stock is trading now
it's much higher than the deal announced
last weekend suggesting that investors
think there's going to be
other offers or some kind of other value
something else might happen is that
something you would expect for the
Treasury Department be involved in
keeping some some new bidder or new new
intervention in that in that company's
potential acquisition by JP Morgan is
that something that creates risk for the
broader markets oh we constantly are
monitoring the markets we're very
vigilant and reviewing what's going on
in the markets how markets are reacting
I'm not going to speculate what's going
to happen with other individual
companies or what an individual
institutions may or may not do but I can
assure you we want to do and see
activities and market participants
taking actions that will enhance the
stability of our markets and enhance
liquidity in the capital markets so back
to Greg's question here's this massive
intervention in the workings of
investment banks and a bunch of Wall
Street rich guys why shouldn't there be
a similarly massive intervention to help
ordinary home buyers who got in over
their heads or or facing hard times well
in terms of what the Fed did and what
other regulators are doing to help
facilitate orderliness in our capital
markets I do think that helps everybody
given their vested interest in ensuring
that financial institutions can lend to
them and that their stability in their
investments that they make into the
capital markets with respect to some of
the other challenges that individual
homeowners have and the challenges given
the headwinds to the economy in the
housing sector there are a series of
actions that we have supported to help
ameliorate some of the challenges in the
housing sector but this is a very real
challenge that the economy is facing but
we've been facing it for almost two
years now and I have a great deal of
confidence in our economy it's very
resilient its continued to grow but
certainly we have some real challenges
today and we're addressing those in the
housing sector and we're also looking to
do all we can to mitigate the spillover
from the events in that capital markets
and in the credit markets spilling over
into the real
onna me so these events of the last
couple of weeks have not changed your
stance of administration's stance on for
example the kind of proposal that
Senator Dodd and Congressman Frank are
working on to buy up mortgages and try
to return some stability to to that
section of mortgage market well we share
the ambition to have the housing market
place work through we have put forth a
series of initiatives and our focus
going back to last summer was to try to
prevent of as many foreclosures that
could be prevented that where there was
affordability by the homeowners and our
focus is on the homeowners and we had
facilitated the establishment of this
alliance hope now alliance with
nonprofit counselors with investors with
financial institutions with lenders with
other product providers to really
improve the efficiency and the
coordination associated with preventing
affordable foreclosures and that group
is working well we're making progress
and that's a big part of what needs to
be done the FHA is playing a role we
would really like to see Congress move
forward with FHA modernization that
would allow the FHA to play even a
larger role and help more homeowners so
that would certainly be a constructive
part of an overall solution and third
the gses they've played an important
role in this marketplace and we saw some
actions as recently as yesterday by
their regulator and hopefully that will
also be part of the solution to
contribute to that and we want to
continue to work and see Congress move
forward with comprehensive GSE reform I
think the important thing to recognize
whether we're talking about the
challenges in the capital markets with
respect to credit or challenges in the
housing sector of the economy that there
are a host of related issues which
combine to create these challenges and
as such the solution to address these
challenges will also be a combination of
different initiatives and actions
and so we're very engaged on both fronts
what is GSE I'm sorry
government-sponsored entities
enterprises so Fannie Mae Freddie Mac
okay thank you are the taxpayers at risk
of losing money as a consequence of the
the money that the Fed has lent to bear
stearns and now plans to lend to other
broker dealers well the Federal Reserve
is a function of capability of a lending
facility and they have policies and
practices in place to ensure that loans
that they make out to the institutions
are collateralized and they set the
guidelines for that we read that the
Treasury and the Federal might actually
make money on this loan is that true the
terms and conditions of that are
probably best addressed by the Federal
Reserve okay going back to a new
question for a second the specifics of
the dodd-frank proposals they would like
to go beyond the steps that you and the
Congress have already talked about with
respect to FHA modernization and make
its resources available to guarantee as
much as four hundred billion dollars in
mortgages as long as the lenders write
down the value of those mortgages can
you tell us what the administration sees
some value whether they want to at least
negotiate this whether they're willing
to perhaps meet them halfway on this
proposal yeah our focus is really making
what we have moved forward with as
effective as it possibly can be we feel
that is the best thing to be doing it is
working we don't want to see things that
could compromise or undermine that
effort but as I said there are a host of
other things that could be done I think
FHA modernization would really be an
additional step that would be very very
constructive to see and the gses
continue to play a role in facilitating
that type of capital being deployed into
the mortgage marketplace Tony you've
worked in financial markets for a long
time the private sector before you came
to the Treasury Department what what is
surprised you about how this event the
series of events over the last several
months is played out what what are the
stress points or tensions or problems in
the financial markets that you never
could have imagined well I think there
are a host of issues and
is actually something that we have been
doing in parallel obviously our first
and most important focus is on working
through the current challenges in the
capital markets and to mitigate those
implications into our real economy we
want to make sure that our real economy
can continue to grow so the companies
have access to capital so they can make
investments continue to hire people have
jobs growth etc with respect to the
capital markets in addition to getting
through the current challenges we've
also been working over the last several
months in a parallel way to look at how
did we get here and I talked a little
bit earlier about the trigger event and
some of the weaknesses that helped
facilitate starting this turmoil but the
same point in time we've also looked at
the weaknesses that help enable this
turmoil to spread across asset classes
across geography and to see how
pronounces become and over the last
several months and I use the word we
it's not just my colleagues and I at
Treasury it's also our colleagues within
the regulatory community at the federal
level as comprising the president's
working group on financial markets and
we have looked at all of the underlying
practices and evaluated those to address
what were the weaknesses that enable
this to spread and more importantly what
recommendations should we put forth that
would help mitigate some of those
weaknesses so that we can make our
capital market stronger and reduce the
likelihood of this type of turmoil in
the future and just last week secretary
Paulson in his capacity as the chairman
of the President's working group on
financial markets which also includes
the Federal Reserve the Securities and
Exchange Commission and the Commodity
Futures Trading Commission put forth a
policy statement which diagnosed all of
these weaknesses and also put forth a
broad array of recommendations that we
feel when implemented and that's the
stage we're moving to now will
significantly address those weaknesses
make our capital market stronger can you
give us one or two examples of problems
and the solutions that you put forward
sure be happy to I think one of the key
issues to recognize here is that we
didn't want to get into
the finger-pointing this is where the
blame lies as we looked at all of the
practices in the capital markets we
recognized that there was room for
improvement by everybody that include
mortgage originators that included
issuers of securitized credit that
included the role of the rating agencies
that included the role of investors that
included the rule about their financial
institutions and importantly it also
included the role of the regulatory
community so across the board we said
everybody can look at their existing
practices put forth recommendations that
we felt would help strengthen those
practices and said let's get to work
addressing these but let's be really
thoughtful about how we implement these
so that we don't exacerbate the current
challenges that we're working through
but for example with respect to rating
agencies we said they need to in what r
rating agencies rating agencies are
firms that are responsible for
evaluating certain securities that then
are issued into the marketplace and
providing a rating these are the ones
for example that would say this bond is
worth it is triple-a and therefore its
top quality exactly and part of the
challenge that we've had in the capital
markets is given the relatively long
period of very benign economic and
financial conditions investors became
somewhat complacent about risk and some
perhaps over allied on ratings who
looked at a specific security and said
oh it's triple-a and it made some
assessments about what they thought that
meant and one of the recommendations
that we put forth is we need to do a
better job of sensitizing all market
participants and regulators about risk
so we need to increase the awareness of
risk and focus not just on returns but
also on risk and a big part of what has
exacerbated some of the challenges and
the solutions and working through the
turmoil to some of the complexity that
has started to become so pervasive in
our capital markets with respect to
structures and with respect to
instruments and in addition to some of
the complexity one of
the corresponding attributes is opacity
and part of one of the broader themes of
the recommendations that we put forth
was to enhance disclosure and to provide
additional information so that investors
are a more aware of risk and when I say
risk broadly defined not just credit
risk or probability of default risk but
to think about liquidity risk to think
about counterparty risk to think about
reputational risk there are a whole host
of aspects that we need market
participants to be more sensitive to and
better manage and so part of the
recommendations were geared towards
providing that information to investors
and financial institutions to a be more
aware of risks but more importantly
better manage it you don't want to point
fingers I'm going to I'm going to ask
you to point fingers is this a is this a
market failure we're experiencing or a
regulatory failure where's it's not a
failure at all is this just the way
markets work and the way capitalism goes
well as I as I look at it I think that
there's a there were certainly
weaknesses certain practices compromised
our discipline in the marketplace which
is a something that we as policymakers
rely very heavily on for investors to
act in their own self-interest and
consistent with the rules and
regulations to have protections for
investors and as we look across the
continuum we felt everybody could
strengthen and enhance and fortify their
their practices that includes regulators
too I think it's a fair point that some
of the regulatory policies and guidance
that was there failed to mitigate some
of the weaknesses in the part by the
market participants so certainly there
are tangible responsible
responsibilities for the regulators to
pick up and move forward on in terms of
putting forth rules and guidance that
will strengthen market discipline and to
work with their entities that they
regulate whether those are investors
rating agencies or financial
institutions and that's true not just
domestically but one of the things we've
learned is how interconnected
capital markets are globally so it
requires a great deal of communication
and coordination across regulators at
both the federal level at the state
level and internationally and so we're
working in close concert with the
foreign regulatory community and we're
working through the financial stability
form in the g7 and they'll be coming out
with additional recommendations in the
weeks ahead Tony with the federal
reserve now lending money to
broker-dealers directly for the first
time basically since it was created in
1913 some people on Congress are
pointing out that now that that money is
at risk the Fed really ought to have
some say in supervising these entities
in fact they argue that possibly the
fact that a very large brokerage firm
nearly failed without anybody realizing
in what hardship it was until almost the
last minute suggests that there is a
case to be made for a reform of the
Prudential oversight but what are your
thoughts on that do you think that
perhaps we do need to think about
whether we need to broaden or revamp the
oversight should there be some role for
the Fed overseeing these firms now that
they are also lending to them well I
think a few thoughts one is we need to
continue to make sure we work through
the current challenges in the markets
this has to be job one and the actions
by the Federal Reserve to help
facilitate orderliness and stability it
is very very important number two with
respect to the presence working group
and the recommendations that we put
forth last week there are a host focused
on many of these issues as they relate
to financial institutions and we need
this communication and coordination by
the various regulators and the SEC in
conjunction with the other bank
regulators are working on reviewing the
practices of our financial institutions
risk management including liquidity risk
management which is really at the heart
of the recent developments and as we
look forward and look at the broader
issues of regulatory structure within
the United States I think we all
recognize
app the framework that we have in place
today is as you suggest Greg is a
reflection of literally decades of
evolution and we have a very fragmented
regulatory structure this is an issue
that secretary Paulson put a light on
last year when we were focused on the
issues surrounding Capital Markets
competitiveness and the Treasury has
been working on reviewing the broader
question the strategic question of is
our regulatory framework for financial
services industry optimally structured
to enable our economy to continue to
thrive and compete in the 21st century
and this is something that the Treasury
will be speaking out on and providing
more insight on in the weeks ahead do
the events of the past weekend and the
Federal Reserve's insertion into you
know the business of lending the
Securities Dealers add a new urgency to
that process or suggest you need to go
and think some more about these issues
does it give you new things to think
about well this is something we've been
spending a great deal of time on and
working on and will be coming out in the
weeks ahead but certainly we as part of
that process we've had extensive
conversations with the regulatory
community and with market participants
we solicited input from the marketplace
and all of that has been factored into
our thinking and our review a lot of
what you've offered both today and in
the president's working group proposal a
couple weeks ago are kind of outlines of
examining flaws in the in the system and
looking for ways to address them when
might we expect some some more
specifically their legislation or
regulations to deal with some of these
holes and is this something that will
call for some kind of sweeping
legislation passed by Congress or this
is something that will just more in kind
of different agencies revising how they
do things well I think first we have to
be sure we don't exacerbate the current
challenges in the capital markets as we
move towards implementation with many of
these recommendations second there's a
lot of market discipline being wrought
out in
capital markets today and so market
participants are moving in the right
direction and making up for some of the
weaknesses of the past but we want to
continue to work with market
participants and find the best way to
move to implement these ideas certainly
the regulators are already engaged with
those that they regulate to review those
practices review those guidance review
those rules and modify them as necessary
so they're consistent with the
recommendations our ambition is to see
the market practices change and we want
to and will continue to monitor market
developments monitor practices in the
marketplace and if those practices are
not moving to in the direction that we
want to see in terms of enhancing market
discipline mitigating systemic risk
strengthening risk management practices
enhancing risk awareness improving the
infrastructure of our capital markets
then will either make additional
recommendations or if necessary if we
need additional regulatory authority I
expect the regulator's to seek it but
we're going to stay on top of this
Secretary has pledged that later at the
end of this year will given a status
report and update on what we've seen and
how it's moving but we're very focused
on ensuring that the weaknesses are
addressed the credit crunch is now topic
number one I'll bet on in restaurants
and homes around dinner tables well
howdy what do you tell people who are
just scared now just plain scary well
investor confidence comes from seeing
capital markets effectively function to
know that there's regulators monitoring
what's going on in the financial
institutions and the health of those
financial institutions I think it's
important to recognize we are making
progress and some significant
developments have occurred we've seen
financial institutions take these
writedowns we've seen many financial
institutions take actions to strengthen
their balance sheets I think it's
important for people to recognize that
our financial institutions entered into
this period of turmoil with strong
capital ratios and we are continuing to
see policymakers stay
very engaged taking appropriate action
facilitating liquidity in the capital
markets and we need market participants
to do the same it's a shared
responsibility but obviously our focus
is just that to see the capital markets
working well to make sure that credit is
being able to be extended to those that
need it and that they have confidence in
our capital markets but we have very
diverse capital markets very resilient
capital markets and I'm quite confident
that we'll continue to work through
these challenges and as we do and as
these recommendations are implemented
I'm quite confident that our capital
markets will be that much stronger
Anthony Ryan has been assistant
secretary of the Treasury for financial
markets for 15 months now thank you very
much for joining us on newsmakers thank
you very much for having me thanks Neil
Irwin over the Washington Post and Greg
it from The Wall Street Journal what'd
you hear well I hear the administration
still trying to in some sense stick to
the message that let's let the
initiatives that we've already announced
to do their job before we move to more
radical solutions such as those that
some Democrats on Capitol Hill are
talking about a guest from an analytical
perspective you want to ask whether they
really have that kind of time you know
it seemed that every week the crisis
gets worse than a new sector of the
market falls under stress and used type
of firm has troubled meeting its
financing obligations and when people
sort of see their 401ks suffering
because of these mysterious market
blowing up there's a lot of pressure on
the administration to act and to show
momentum and so you really have to
wonder how long they can sort of like
hold off the the pressure to do
something more especially on the front
of expanding the Federal Housing
Administration lending ability the you
know Congress is out this week and so
will there be a big change when they get
back I mean all at once these members
will all come coming together and they
will not have been together since the
Bear Stearns issues well that's the
thing it's whatever the merits of the
administration would argue that trying
to create some kind of program to help
mortgage markets to help homebuyers
directly that it's fraught with
technical problems and challenges how do
you avoid just bailing out banks and
people who made bad loans how do you
avoid bailing out speculators who made
bad bets and did you know engage in
irresponsible behavior and they're right
it's very tricky to try and design some
program that doesn't have those faults
in it that said the political
environment may have changed when you
have a situation where 30 billion
dollars is at stake to make this
acquisition of bear stearns happen it's
kind of hard to do that and then say
well we're not going to intervene in
these private markets we're not going to
have any bailouts especially when home
buyers on the hook that's that it's a
much trickier and harder thing for
Congress and administration to try and
arrive at do you think the
administration represented by mr. Ryan
it's been successful in their PR effort
part of this that's very difficult to
answer because you have to calibrate
that against how the environment around
them keeps changing and frankly the
Federal Reserve has the same problem
some people have criticized them for you
know being slow initially to trim
interest rates and communicating a
message which seemed too focused on the
problem of inflation and then the
problem of the economy but the fact of
the matter is that events are really
moving at light speed now I mean what we
saw with basically the situation of bear
stearns going to the brink of failure in
a matter of days is that today's markets
move much more rapidly and so the
message that the administration puts out
this week may seem suddenly like
antiquated out of date by the following
week it's a it's a tremendous problem
for them they they have a kind of free
market approach this they want to
respect private markets and and not not
bail out Wall Street not bail out people
who made bad decisions but the worstest
thing becomes the heart of that line
becomes to imagine in the presidential
working group as we go forward from here
how much should people pay attention to
that group itself is it key as we look
to the future not so far and what
they've done sadly I mean to use an
analogy in some sense they're debating
how to improve the fire code while the
fire is still raging you know what I
mean I mean it's it has to be done it's
it's important work but right now the
real the pressure is on to solve put the
fire out and that's where people are
still struggling to find the right tools
and use them with enough aggressiveness
now the whole working group came into
effect in the last problem we had this
in 87 do you think they'll be changed
in the working group coming at this well
the working group is just kind of the
the group of these agencies that deal
with these issues the important thing is
you know the working group is existed
for 20 years and for a lot of that time
it they met four times a year and didn't
do much of anything under secretary
Paulson treasurer secretary Paulson it
has taken on a more dominant role and
dealing with the regulatory and
financial infrastructure we would expect
that to only continue and expand and now
what should be we'd be looking for in
the next week is there is there any way
to look to to get a feel for what you're
looking for I think there are two areas
that I would watch Connie the first one
would be to see where the administration
starts making noises publicly about
moving towards the Democrats on Capitol
with respect to expanding the Federal
Housing Administration is lending
capacity the second thing I would look
to see would be more thoughtfulness
about how to reform the regulatory
structure as I was trying to get across
in my questions to Assistant Secretary
Ryan now that the Federal Reserve is in
the business of lending not just to
banks but to securities brokerage is
there's a really reasonable question to
be asked well shouldn't they have some
role in oversight over them so and on
Capitol Hill then when the Congress
comes back you mentioned Congressman
Frank you mentioned senator Dodd are
those going to be the key people to
watch they are senator Dodd chairs the
Senate Banking Committee chairman frank
of the house financial services
committee they're kind of the key nodes
of trying to work out solutions to this
the thing is just the mechanics are very
difficult trying to design some kind of
proposal to deal with home buyers and
the excesses in the mortgage market that
have built as Tony said over many years
is a very very difficult thing they will
be trying to put together a package they
already have some broad ideas out there
if they can put together a law and get
it passed it will surprise a lot of
people then it's your job to explain
that very difficult thing to in language
that makes sense to the regular American
audience thank you very both